to put a finer point on it they've
they've surveyed men from around the
world cross culturally cross continent
everything and doesn't matter if the
guy's 20 or 65 years old they all say
that that women are most beautiful when
they're 22 22 23 you know as the average
right so basically from 23 on for women
they're on the they're on the decline
right like women are typically more most
valuable to men and most attractive to
men around the age of 23 there's a whole
bunch of reasons for that like um
there's there's a notion of uh fertility
of course because you know the primary
reason that men choose women is their
fertility and their ability to bring
them children so they can pass on their
legacy their name their DNA sort of
thing there's also problems that arise
as women sort of get older too right
like as they spend time with more men
and share their bodies with more men
their value becomes less and less
because they carry more and more baggage
like a lot of men see that as a problem
too right so there's a lot of things
that exist as you know kind of women
lean into their 30s and I mean one of
the things that I'm trying to do with
the show and I have this conversation
I'm just trying to have honest
conversations and open dialogue and some
back and forth discussion with women and
hold up a a mirror and just say hey look
you know there's a few things here that
you're probably not looking at that
you've been ignoring that you might want
to have a look at and contemplate so I
know it's not going to change Minds in
like five or 10 minutes or anything like
that but I think it's worth a
conversation so what do you think that
women over 30 bring to the table well I
I don't care about their
job right because I've got my own money
and women don't share their pot of gold
with men anyway right it's it's men that
are willing to share their pot of gold
with women and you know show them a good
time in a life and bring them along for
cool to do it's not often women
will be like hey I'm going to go to uh
grease for 3 weeks in the summer but I
know you're broke as but I'm going
to take you along with me cuz you're a
funny guy and you're nice sort of thing
like that that's not usually how it goes
like they'd rather go with their
girlfriends right um or go solo and just
find a guy over there to have fun with
sort of thing so um it's it's certainly
not
money um not being in debt is at least a
bare minimum I mean if you're 30 then I
would expect you not to be in debt like
I would expect you not to have like a
up life and just nothing but a
pile of Handbags and shoes to show for
yourself and St stacks of credit card
debt because your problems will
eventually become my problem so a bare
minimum is you know having some basic
Financial skills right um but I have the
expectation that they're feminine that
they're a compliment to my life that
they do things to add value to my life
they ask me questions like hey Rich you
know I see you're working on this
project what can I do to help you out to
help you know move that along sort of
thing um I look for you know culinary
skills most guys don't cook so they want
to check that you know can show up in
their life and you know make them
healthy tasty meals and feed them you
know there's an old old saying you know
if you want to keep a guy around keep
his uh stomach full and his balls empty
right uh it's as simple as that you know
for some relationships but uh you know
there's multiple pieces to the puzzle
but that's just one of the that's two of
the big pieces for for a lot of guys
yeah but those would be the main things
right like I'm not looking for funny
I'll do standup comedy for funny uh
loyalty
um would you say loyal fun and honest I
kind of expect her to be loyal fun and
honest you know if she's going to be
around me like it's a bare minimum like
she wouldn't even get the time of day if
she was uh you know disloyal not fun or
not honest like if she had a
pathological uh lying trait to her like
I would pick it up pretty quickly right
uh if she was dishonest I would pick it
up I would expect loyalty out of a woman
I mean if if you're going to come to me
and say hey Rich I dig your Vibe where
do we stand I don't want to share you
other guys are invisible blah blah blah
I would expect loyalty it's like
unquestionable like you're with me now I
own you like your mind you know sort of
thing not in the sense like I own you
like you're on a call or like you're my
dog sort of thing but you're now mine
and that's final right um so those would
be the things that you know be standard
but there's other things that come along
with that you know for guys too like
there's detrimental things like you know
is she a single mom she bring kids from
prior relationships into my life that's
going to complicate it unnecessarily and
she shared her body with 30 40 50 other
guys that's going to complicate my life
that's going to bring baggage she's
probably going to be Alpha widowed by
some of these guys she's probably going
to have some guys from her past around
which I'm not going to tolerate right um
that's not out of jealousy or out of
control that's like I drive a nice car
I'm not going to park my nice car in a
shitty neighborhood and leave it
unlocked overnight and hope nothing bad
happens to it something bad is probably
going to happen to it so if I have a gal
in my life that wants to hang out with
guys that she was intimate with in the
past something bad is probably going to
happen at some point right because if I
expect loyalty then I need to make sure
that she's going to be loyal and that
I'm not going to allow bad things to
happen like parking my nice car in a
shitty neighborhood sort of thing right
that's when bad stuff starts to happen
so like Towing the line being a
compliment to my life you know uh I'm
going to use the term letting me lead
because I think that modern women today
probably want to hear it that way rather
than following my lead um you know and
encouraging
uh greatness and that leadership to uh
grow and you know facilitate into what
it needs to be because women have a hard
time with that you know they want to sit
down and they want to have like a
conversation about equalness right you
know we're equal partners and you know
well I'll I'll just take out the garbage
this time or okay well then are you
going to shovel the driveway too uh when
there's a bang in the night and we're
lying in bed together am I just going to
Elbow you and be like okay well you get
this one because I wash the dishes
tonight right there's kind of masculine
roles and feminine roles and I think
that most woman out there would have the
expectation that the guy would get out
of bed and beat the out of whoever
broke in the house and broke the glass
right and they want to be protected so
like there's all of these moving pieces
and it's not as simple as oh it's a 10
or 25 piece puzzle I think there's a lot
of pieces to the puzzle and there's a
lot of understanding that has to come
from both places and you can have a
really really good relationship with a
chick over a long term if you both
surrender to your natural roles and
accept you know what's good for you and
what's good for her and sort of work on
stuff together I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out